the only thing more bizarre than a 16
foot or nearly five meter tall statue
depicting a five-legged human-headed
bull with wings which by the way was
carved out of one massive piece of stone
weighing some 40 imperial tons or 80 000
pounds
yes the only thing stranger than this
statue and the few others like it is how
and where they found them
buried and consumed in earth almost as
if they were devoured by some sort of
cataclysmic mud flood-like event
these spectacular yet ominous wingbull
sculptures are known as the lamasu and
are among the remnants of the assyrian
empire which made up the heart of
ancient mesopotamia or commonly referred
to as the fertile crescent
and i have to say the only thing more
bizarre than the statues themselves or
how and where they found them which i'll
be discussing more of in just a moment
but the only thing more bizarre than all
of that
is the deliberate continued and
systematic destruction of ancient iraq
which let's not forget just so happens
to be the very land that has long been
referenced as the so-called cradle of
civilization the very place where the
sumerians emerged and when i say
systematic destruction of ancient iraq
wait until you see and hear what i'm
going to show you later in this video
because if you thought that these were
nothing more than a number of angry
violent
stupid people bent on destruction or
some jaded religious crusade i regret to
tell you that that is not the case and
rather something far more nefarious took
place to orchestrate their methodical
destruction which you'll find to be
quite disturbing in fact i'd even
venture to say that once you hear and
see what i'm about to show you it's just
one of those things that you'll never
forget
now before i get to that let me first
share a few fascinating things to lead
up to it and i must say that i am still
pinching myself when i reflect on that i
was one of so few people to ever see and
touch these lamasco statues in person
during my nearly year-long deployment to
northern iraq in 2009 and 2010
including being stationed at ford
operating base in the city of mosul
which is in the modern day location of
ancient biblical city of nineveh those
of you who have followed me for some
time have heard me share this unique
experience before as i happen to be at
the right place and at the right time to
have this once in a lifetime encounter
and although my thoughts on the invasion
of iraq have evolved significantly in
the years following and you know what
screw it i'll just be blunt
i had volunteered after 9 11 and then
later on i had believed that i was going
to go and liberate the iraqi people
but after some time i eventually figured
out that i had been egregiously lied to
by the various powers that be
and ultimately the invasion of iraq was
unjustified illegal and one massive
crime against humanity but
all those wonderful thoughts aside i am
nonetheless selfishly grateful that i
was afforded the unlikely chance to
visit a site that countless researchers
historians and archaeologists from
around the world had long sought to
visit firsthand but couldn't as it was
virtually off limits for decades
and unfortunately any opportunity there
once was has since passed as back in
2014 these statues attained global
attention when isis invaded northern
iraq and completely decimated this
entire site which made up the gates of
negal
i remember watching this on the news
when it happened and being in total
disbelief that this was occurring at the
exact same place that i had been
now this particular statue here is from
that same location but has resided at
the oriental institute museum at the
university of chicago since 1930 and i
had the great pleasure of visiting
during a trip to chicago and i have to
say that this is one little-known gem of
a museum
and if you ever find yourself in chicago
which by the way is a lovely town
this museum is a must visit as they have
an astonishing set of artifacts that are
amongst the oldest and rarest from all
of ancient human civilizations
they even have a wonderful collection
from ancient egypt as well in fact they
have more than 5 000 total artifacts in
the museum on display and you could
spend hours and hours looking at
everything they have on exhibit
and although 5 000 artifacts is a lot it
is sadly only a small percentage of the
more than 350
000 total relics they have in this
museum's catalog
do the math and that is actually less
than one and a half percent of their
total inventory i feel that that's worth
mentioning because it is unfortunately
the case at most any museum as a vast
majority of all the artifacts ultimately
sit forgotten within their dusty boxes
down in the bowels of museum basements
what i wouldn't do to go take a gander
through their archives but that aside
this statue is one of so few that remain
in the world today
however you can still find a few others
scattered throughout the world including
at the iraq museum in baghdad a few at
the louvre in france which by the way i
really want to go to
and a couple more at the metropolitan
museum of art in new york city
i am pleased to mention though that
these artifacts were not stolen and they
were actually given to the oriental
institute by the countries they
originate from at least in a few
examples that i had read about
particularly this statue they were
essentially given as gifts for helping
to excavate these remarkable sites now
you have to see this in person to truly
grasp its size and eminence i'm 5'10 or
178 centimeters and what i saw in person
with my own eyes was truly something
else
the very shoulder of just one of its
legs is above my head and when you're up
close you understand what a behemoth
this thing is
the torso itself is so large that you
cannot observe the entirety unless you
take at least a few steps back
and keep in mind that all of these
photos you're seeing were captured on
ultra wide camera lens which thus
distorts the true depth and width
pictures simply do not do this thing
justice for what your eyes witness first
hand and by the way like i mentioned at
the beginning of this video it has five
legs
you see four of them when viewing it
from the side which gives the statue the
appearance of essentially walking
forward however when you view it from
the front you'll see the fifth leg and
the bull at that time appears to just be
standing still
it's incredible
and this precision of this stone is
nothing short of excellent
the nuanced details ranging from the
feathers to the braided beard and all of
its curls as well as its lips and eyes
and by the way notice that it also has
ears of a bull as well and observe the
fine cuneiform script written in between
the legs
there is just so much focused detail to
this beautiful statue that when you're
in front of it you know you're in the
presence of greatness and although it
has a rather striking or ominous look to
it i felt delighted to be within its
company and to help us further
appreciate what an undertaking it would
have been to create this thing you
should know that what this statue has
survived over the course of thousands of
years besides the fact that it was
buried following whatever happened to it
in order to break it in half in the
first place in fact when they excavated
it they found that it was broken into
one dozen pieces
which is so interesting because again
what type of forces would have been
involved to break this thing apart to
that extent
but it's burial and mud aside you'll
further appreciate the precision carved
into the hardness of this stone when you
learn that following its excavation
a building literally fell on top of it
yet caused so little damage to all the
subtle details this thing was built to
last and every bit of the precision
would certainly have been challenging
especially when you consider the
unbelievably strong nature of this type
of stone
simply compare it to one that was
destroyed in a rock and just see how
difficult it was to do so despite taking
a literal jackhammer to do it but i
digress for a moment and going back to
the statue in chicago
you'd hardly realize the damage it
endured unless you observe it from the
back where you can see how they pieced
it together using gypsum and speaking of
the back of it keep in mind that this
statue once lined the walls of the
throne room to king sargon ii
which brings me back to the question as
to how and why it was destroyed and
consumed in earth in the first place
because history suggests that although
mesopotamia was made up of multiple
empires such as the sumerians the
assyrians and babylonians there still
would have been a overall continuity of
civilization itself and that no
cataclysmic event
uh would have differentiated the changes
in empires and governments at least not
that we are aware of so
it makes me wonder why they would have
allowed such an impressive palace which
by the way was said to be one of the
most spectacular ever created up into
that point
so why would they have allowed the sands
of time to just consume it
that is unless something else we may not
be aware of could have facilitated its
quick burial that's a question i i just
don't know but i do have questions about
the nature in which they they found
these ruins but if there is one question
related to these statues it's why was
there such an orchestrated attempt to
ensure that so many of them would be
destroyed
i mean when you look at the specifics of
the isis invasion of iraq it was nothing
short of sophisticated
those who chose to annihilate this site
went totally out of their way to do so
and not only that they went to the
challenging extent of bringing in heavy
equipment to accomplish the task
make no mistake this was a highly
coordinated undertaking and not done so
at the behest of a bunch of stupid
idiots behaving like fools exhorting
some sort of perverted false ideology
no there is far more to this than meets
the eye
and this is the part that i alluded to
earlier in the video involving a
conspiracy to destroy ancient iraq
we all recognize this guy don't we and
although i have no doubt this man is
guilty of a few things but the one thing
i heard him say when addressing the isis
of invasion of iraq and all the
destruction that followed
he stated something to the media that so
few people have ever heard so here is a
minute and a half clip from 2015 which
is absolutely worth watching and just
listen to what he had to say in the
context of the creation of isis and
their invasion of iraq as it's very very
important so here we go
[Music]
foreign
you know i hate to admit it but he's
telling the truth and what he said was
something i had already concluded way
before he had ever said it in fact when
isis first invaded iraq i remember
talking to a buddy over the phone who i
deployed with and we both came to the
same conclusion that these are
mercenaries like this is this is not a
pack of just religious extremists that
are like out to break something and take
over a piece of land this was so
sophisticated i mean i saw and i
understood that these are legitimately
mercenaries they are far too
sophisticated in the context of military
movement and it was done so in a matter
manner that exceeded the sloppiness of
an angry violent group of religious
extremists like i mentioned this was a
legit military operation and many people
who have never served in combat
operations do not realize the multiple
facets of discipline as well as
communications involved for it to
function as such but more so than that
these people went out of their way to
completely massacre the peaceful
populace of yazidi people that made up
that region
they killed the men and the children and
took the women as their slave wives
this happened everyone in the know knew
it it was all over the news at the time
and the rest of the world didn't seem to
care and the reality is that anyone that
would massacre innocent people including
children and then
kidnap and rape their own you know to
take a slave wife
that type of person is a complete and
total psychopath and you know what
that is what a mercenary army looks like
the types of people that would literally
kill innocent people for money are the
types of people that would choose to
become mercenaries in the first place
these people committed literal genocide
and i have to say that it's depressingly
remarkable to see how few people cared
about this despite it again being all
over the news to anyone that was paying
attention but on top of all of that just
to point out another fact which tells us
that the isis invaders were actual
mercenaries paid by someone when you
consider the significant fact that so
many of them were using american-made
m4s and m16s instead of the ak-47
that right there is highly telling and
only further validates putin's alluding
statements that they were paid and armed
by others so
yeah i believe him and the very look and
tone on his voice in his face when he
said that screamed of the truth and by
the way a side point but
ever since he declared monsanto a
terrorist organization and all the
efforts he made to rid his country of
non-organic and gmo foods i knew that
there was more to this guy than what the
media would let the masses believe i
mean i'm not some putin apologist but i
seek the truth from anyone that would
dare speak it and
going back to his specific iraq comments
the very fact that once isis took over
they began selling more oil than iraq
had ever done so in its history
is unbelievably significant because
think about it this was not some group
of stupid extremists these people
psychopaths as they were were clearly
having their strings pulled by powers
operating in the shadows and far above
them
i'm telling you this whole thing was
highly sophisticated and methodical and
is in every sense a true conspiracy so
the question for me now becomes
why did whoever that had the power to
orchestrate the invasion itself and the
subsequent destruction
why did they choose to ensure that these
ancient biblical sites would be erased
from history forever
and you want to hear something else
that's creepy
the purpose of these lamasu statues were
said to be protective deities meant to
keep demonic entities away
so it's quite interesting that the
closest thing to an actual demonic force
would indeed seek out to obliterate them
in such purposeful fashion
interesting right i'll be very curious
to hear what everyone else's thoughts
are on all of this whether it's just the
statues themselves which are spectacular
but also the clear intention to destroy
these sites within ancient iraq
many people have proposed conspiracies
in the past involving certain ancient
human history relics in iraq and
afghanistan that some have suggested was
the one of the purposes for going in
there in the first place
it's hard to tell what's true and what
isn't but all i know is that there's
something to this situation that makes
my eyebrow go up so that said hit the
like button and subscribe i have more
interesting videos to come and leave a
comment sharing your thoughts on any and
all the things discussed in this video
but that said my name is jimmy corsetti
my channel is called bright insight and
stay tuned to another fascinating video
take care everybody